[Music]
what is light what is light Laser relays
what is that's a good question it's like
isn't it an element light is brightness
I guess we have auras which are light
yes yeah it lights up the room it makes
it not dark what's the difference
between blue light red light the color
it goes in your eyes and then you see
stuff they range from white to red to
orange to green it's like the chakras of
your body can you see my aura no is it
too bright oh it's very sunny out here
today does that make it harder to see
someone's aura necessarily if I was to
explain it to a blind person it yeah it
would be it would be the difference you
see nothing whatsoever as a blind person
whereas I see things in front of me to
be fair the question of what light is is
not an easy one for centuries the
greatest minds and science debated this
issue in the late 1600s Newton proposed
that light was a stream of particles or
corpuscles he proposed this in his
treatise optics but at the same time a
Dutch physicist named Huygens proposed
that light was a wave and this debate
raged on until it was settled by the
experiment I've recreated today Thomas
Young's double-slit experiment to make
sure I got the experiment right I went
to the original source with the help of
Brady Haran I managed to get into the
vault underneath the Royal Society in
London there I found Thomas Young's
handwritten notes from 1803
I brought into the Sunbeam s card about
one thirtieth of an inch read and
observed its shadow either on the wall
or on other cards held at different
distances besides the fringes of colours
on each side of the shadow the shadow
itself was divided by similar parallel
fringes smaller dimension
this is an experiment so simple that you
could make it at home and yet so fiddly
that I have never seen it before done
with sunlight I was thinking about doing
it in a box like a like a fridge box you
could take it out of this we're taking
it out on the street I possibly
interview you guys for about a minute
we're doing a science experiment I have
here is an empty box and this is a
little eyepiece where we can look in and
this is a hole and I'm gonna place this
slide above that hole and if you look
closely you'll see that there's two
openings very narrow opening side by
side it's a double slit now before we
have a look we need to tilt it towards
the Sun a little bit so we want the Sun
to hit this double slit directly what
are we gonna see on the bottom the
obvious thing you think you're gonna see
as you can see two two lines two lines
on the bottom of the box
two bright bands yeah I think it'll be
one one lines of two I can expect to see
the whole box lit up probably a
kaleidoscope of some sort a bunch of
colors probably gay rainbow different
colors there have a look you expected to
see kind of one line is that what you
see no I see dogs how many it's one
circle Oh years one there's one in the
middle strongest to either side the two
on the outside are multicolored and the
one in the middle is just Wyatt I'm kind
of a rainbow the rainbow of color as
well quite a few colors and lots of
little dots like there are more dots
appearing I think I can even see more
dots spreading along yeah that's amazing
yeah I can see tons of darts no not tons
but I can see dots but Erding yeah
definitely yeah that's incredible
and that's just nothing else apart from
two slits to slit
that's incredible but all we're doing is
we're putting a light through to very
narrow slits side by side how does this
make any sense there's some kind of
principle involved that the average
person is not familiar with it's the
only explanation now I'm really confused
by it but I like to find out why people
were debating is light or wave or is it
made of particles so what causes that
well if light were behaving as particles
you would expect them to go through each
slit and just produce a bright spot
underneath so we would see two bright
spots on the bottom of the box
but if lights behaving as waves then the
wave from one slit can interact with the
waves from the other slit I've got a
demonstration here on a little pond
where we can see this with water waves I
have two sources of ripples which are
basically like the two slits when I
create ripples with a single source they
travel out with circular wave fronts
nothing particularly surprising there
but if I add a second source of ripples
then we start getting an interesting
pattern
[Music]
this pattern is created by the ripples
from the two sources interacting with
each other where they meet up Peaks with
peaks and troughs with troughs the
amplitude of the wave is increased
that's what we call constructive
interference but if the peak from one
wave meets up with the trough from the
other then we get destructive
interference and there's basically no
wave there and this is exactly what was
happening with the light when the light
from one slit met up peaks with peaks
and troughs with troughs they'd
constructively interfered and produced a
bright spot but if the trough from the
wave from one slit met up with the peak
of the wave from the other slit they
would destructively interfere and you
wouldn't see any light there it's light
canceling itself out this is basically
the same is like having two drops of
water fall in a swimming pool that's
right exactly the same overlap as this
ripple over overlap sa-do's ripples and
down the bottom you get a series of you
get like a bright spot and then a dark
spot and a bright spot they have dark
spot than a bright spot
now there's a slight complication which
is that sunlight is composed of many
different colors and they have different
wavelengths so obviously they're going
to meet up at slightly different points
and that's what caused the rainbow
effects as we go further from the
central maximum so you saw the ones to
the right we're slightly colored yeah
this type of sparking the reds are gonna
meet up at different places than the
blues and that's all that makes the
color differences different wavelengths
exactly that's amazing so the difference
between the red been over there and the
green the green part is just I'm seeing
that it's just different winglet and
that's how we bring in all these
beautiful colors all around those
exactly that's amazing I'm amazed thank
you
you
now you may have noticed in that
experiment that the light on the bottom
of the box was not in the shape of slits
rather they were more kind of round
blobs and I want to know why that is can
you write an answer for me in the
comment section and I'll give you a hint
one of the videos I've linked kind of is
suggestive of the answer so convincing
were the results of Young's double slit
experiment that the scientific community
concluded that light must be a wave
there is no way it could be a particle